if we're going to do the emotional
support animal thing at all and if
you're allowed to bring your dog on a
plane then I don't see any reason why
you can't bring the snake the the
special status and privilege we give to
dogs doesn't make any sense to me so if
we're gonna do that like if I have to
sit next to your dog on a plane because
I don't see any like you might see a
difference you might say well a dog's
totally different I don't see it to me
animal's an animal and I don't want to
fly with an animal so for allowing that
then yeah bring the snake on too you
know we make exceptions now there so so
dogs are capable of actually providing a
real service to human beings so a seeing
eye dog or something like that then that
that's different but anything where it's
emotional support it just makes me feel
good to have this animal around if
anything we should have more of this
just like Britain make the the plane
into a full-on petting zoo bring your
goats on chickens whatever because
they're not doing a beverage service
then you got a cow there you can for for
milk and whatever